رده فعل الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب كانت حديثه من حوله فكيف كان وقع
لائحه الاتهام الجنائيه على ترامب
منهم من قال بان ترامب كان منزعجا وغاضبا
ومصدوما ومن هم من قال بانه ظل هادئا جدا
ورزينا وفقا لواشنطنبوست
الرئيس الامريكي السابق بحسب مصادر مقربه
تبلغ الخبر بمكالمه هاتفيه ثم بدا بالتحرك
اتصالات بالجمهوريين في الكونجرس ووعود
بالمحاربه حتى البراءه والدفع بالمظلوميه
الرئيس الامريكي السابق سيمثل امام محكمه
من هات يوم الثلاثاء القادم قبل ان يضطر
للوقوف امام قاضن للاستماع الى التهم
الجنائيه الموجهه اليه تحت حمايه امنيه
مشدده وسط توقعات من احد مستشاريه بان
يظهر الرئيس السابق دقيقا وحذرا خاصه وان
هذه تعد سابقه سياسيه وتاريخيه قد يستفيد
منها ترامب كثيرا ويستغلها في حملته
الانتخابيه للعام 2024
عندما يسلم ترامب نفسه سيتم حجزه في
الغالب مثل اي شخص اخر يواجه التهم ستؤخذ
بصماته من دون تقييد يديه ربما وسيتمتع
بحمايه الخدمه السريه ومن شبه المؤكد انه
سيطلق سراحه في اليوم نفسه
الفريق القانوني الترامب وفريق حملته
امضوا اسابيع في التحضير لصدور لائحه
الاتهام ضده بحثوا خلالها خطه الهجوم
باستخدام ورقه الدوافع السياسيه ضد مدعي
عام مقاطعه من هاتن ومحاميه السابق وهو
احد الشهود الرئيسيين في القضيه
ونداءات لجمع التبرعات والحلفاء
القانونيين والسياسيين والاعلاميين